my name is Afshin I mean I'm going to
graduate in december two thousand nine
from carnegie mellon's heinz call it
adelaide campus
I think we have one of the best
faculties available in Australia I would
say and I'm very lucky to be here the
faculty is very dedicated and they take
extra effort to ensure that students are
getting all the material things being
taught because we come from different
backgrounds and different cultures and
especially learning new language and
talking in English and they take care of
all of that and a lot of us are not with
the same background a public policy and
mathematics and economics all the
subjects and new and i must say that a
faculty is very good in teaching us all
of this
I work in a managerial position in a
government organization so I think I'll
be more knowledgeable and better
equipped to manage resources human
resources financial resources economic
resources for all of that yeah
I think it's a very interesting
experience to study here because you're
getting American education in Australia
learning about Australian culture and
learning about America from the American
professors getting them Australian
perspective where else could you get all
of this I mean learning those different
cultures I think it's a great place to
study if you would like more information
please go to wwii in CMU edu a you